quinze minutes avant l'ouverture du
bureau de vote tout est prêt pour
accueillir les électeurs et les
dernières consignes données aux
assesseurs le jour du scrutin je suis là
pour intervenir en cas de besoin quand
les membres du bureau ou une question
j'accueille également donc les électeurs
8 heures il y à déjà du monde devant
l'entrée et chacun a sa raison de voter
de bonheur
avec journée de randonnée donc je vais
le plus tôt possible pour aller voter
tout simplement jo la démo là c'est du
bonheur chez les voleurs matinaux pas
ses premiers électeurs sont convaincus
de la nécessité de voter
deux fois sélectionné et qui nous
touchent des prêts quoi donc de penser c
c'est un canton akwa le dis on a tous le
droit de vote nos côtés en profiter
c'est le seul jour où notre voie elle
compte autant que la voix de tout le
monde à chenôve les bureaux de vote
fermeront à 19h en 2017 pour le premier
tour seulement 44% des électeurs
s'étaient déplacés